We need to formalize how we will precisely measure each type of variability. We
already decided that we're going to use the grand mean, and use the same idea
as standard deviation to measure the spread of the sample means. We'll find
each square deviation from the mean. And in this case we're going to multiply
each square deviation by the sample size. Each square deviation is equivalent
to the area of each of these squares. And then we'll mulitiply this area by
their respective sample size. Here K represents the number of samples. That
means we'll have K sample means. And then we'll add them all up. In this lesson
though, we're assuming that all samples have the same size. So, we can get rid
of the K. n is just a constant across all samples. That means that we can write
the numerator between group variability like this. And then we divide by the
degrees of freedom. When we say formal way of measuring something, that means
we get one number. If we add up each squared deviation of each sample mean from
the grand mean, multiply this by the sample size and then divide by the degrees
of freedom. We get one number that describes between group variability. We need
to do the same for within group variability. And we'll do something similar to
the way we measured between group variability. We'll take the sum of squares
for each individual sample from the mean of each sample, and then we'll divide
by the degrees of freedom. What do you think the degrees of freedom is in this
case? Let's say that we have three samples. More than one option may be
correct.